boys if you want to stay here five days
daddy got five days money it's not like
if you're poor like you're what's wrong
with that yeah there's nothing there's
nothing wrong with that evil yeah
i'm just saying it's different
inadvertently you may be punishing
through punishing your wife for like
saying look i'm the better parent you
may punish the child exactly
but no but he'll see his mother as less
than his father's on the scene because
okay but then she should get a job like
the men have to go get it you can work
that's true because
the woman is inherently punishing the
child by divorcing them anyway yes yeah
if they're too
she's now in a situation where she can't
afford the same lifestyle that husband
can that's on her yeah she's not
entitled to their lifestyle
the poor decision are we just going to
justify that because ignorance
of the effects on the kids because we
all know the statistics of what happens
to children when it when it when the the
nuclear family breaks down
so we can't be
like egotistical or ignorant of the
facts of knowing the effect is going to
have on the child so we still need to
maintain the stability of the kids
upbringing while doing what else needs
to be done i'm saying there should be no
incentive
to leave absolutely correct
but i'm saying with child support there
is an incentive
because that money can elevate the life
her lifestyle why why is she entitled to
his money correct me if i'm wrong but
the model we were talking about now was
if the man were to pay for even just for
the child the money let's assume that
the money is going to the child while
while the child is living with the mom
you were saying that he shouldn't pay
but i'm saying if he is going to the
child while he's the child with the
parent this shouldn't be because you're
taking away the consequence of the
expensive cost of a child for the woman
you're again making it easier for her to
leave
she's left now so i'm trying to benefit
my child it should be a she's already
gone she's already made that bad
decision so then if the man wants to do
that he should be freely able to choose
if he wants he shouldn't be legally
forced yeah her bad decision
i think most men want to take care of
their kids and if it ends amicably most
guys are gonna they're gonna do what's
best for the child what i'm saying is
there shouldn't be a gun to his head
saying you have to pay your baby mama
who destroyed your home especially if he
has access most of the time when i hear
guys ain't trying to pay no money
because they can't see their kids
that's why
do you know what i'm saying i don't hear
man that have their kids all the time
saying i ain't giving no money like i
don't hear that so if the guy's got the
access and he's got the 50 um custody
i'm sure he won't mind handing over the
bread and also if a man's making a lot
more than a woman yeah why is that not
taken into account here when they're
doing custody in the first place because
you're talking about the standard of
living for the child if i make four
times more than
um the wife here like you can't tell me
that the kid's not gonna have a better
life at my house exactly but then i have
to pay for
nah nah
and then and then she's wearing gucci
blood when she's making hm money don't
make sense they think that inherently a
woman will be able to take care of the
child better but if i'm making more
money that puts me in a position
you're gonna have to tilt the mic into
yeah like sorry man that puts me in a
position where i can then take care of
that child better so if in that
situation if i'm in that situation i
should be given custody but if you
really want time it depends on time
though and there are lots of cases like
usher
he had more money than and tamika and he
had the children the most of the time
that there are instances where when the
man is earning more and they do want the
child because they are like i am the
better parent no there's no exceptions
to the rules precisely yes but there are
also lots of fathers who are working a
lot and are like i don't have the time
to rear this child i may have the
financial capacity and i agree that most
hedge fund managers say in your career
your successful hedge fund managers
would they want to look after a child
full-time if they were if they were
separated from their wife
they're getting they need to be honest
that's what i'm saying the child so
they're not going to be the you you'd be
like let's actually fund
the child's lifestyle
do you know what's crazy i have men in
my dms like guys with check marks with
money status and influence that say they
have problems with child custody that's
what they send me their stories and
these are these are men with money so
what does that mean for the average dude
i literally just said to you i have
family members who are currently in this
situation with their baby mothers now
two two kids apiece literally because
they have moved on are not able to see
their kids but they're not the ones i'm
talking about i'm literally talking
about the ones who if the person has
gone and and filed for child support
okay in this country anyway the money
that you're gonna get is really [ __ ]
it's not actually worth it it's not like
in america it's very different you're
not going to be able to fund a lavish
lifestyle on what you're going to be
awarded because it's so calculated it's
not that great i'm saying most of the
time anything what are you doing
it's just better to have an amicable
like reasoning
mediation
somebody else comes in and you split it
and it's it's
it's custody it's 50 50 custody i think
that is the best number
you left though
but you left all you know i mean if you
used to work at nando's and you left you
ain't getting free chicken normally yeah
like that's not talking about elemony
we're talking about child support yeah
the money should be going to feed and
clothes
if he chooses to
get he should get the choice if you if
you get loud
okay
disagree like like he should get the
choice he shouldn't have a gun to his
head saying oh she left you now you have
to pay for the kid but you should want
to this you is fuel yeah yeah you're
right he should he probably does want to
but i'm saying the government should not
make him because if the woman if the
woman's acting if the woman's acting up
and like like not letting him see the
kid or something he should be able to
take away the money that's yeah he
should be able to but it's not right now
i think that is but it's no doubt it's
just like for your child it should be
just like you remove it's just like if a
woman gets pregnant and you say they're
called i don't want to be a dad and she
goes i will too bad and she keeps to you
anyway but they're still going to run
you down for bread you know i mean and
then on the flip side if you say yo like
i want a child and she says i don't but
if child's gone then you have to live
with the consequences either way we
ain't got no say or nothing so it's one
of them ones where if you leave
i don't see why i should have to give
you any money i would want to but i
shouldn't have to because you would have
got money if you didn't leave so in this
same scenario where we don't have a say
on anything and i'm saying well you
should just wear a condom i do or you
should have picked better i do better
wouldn't that be the same for the woman
when she'd get cheated on when you're
like but if you're getting cheated on
you should take responsibility for that
because you pick back is he looking for
the consequences of being cheated on his
difference i'm saying i'm saying i'm
saying there should not he should not
have to pay
that's what i'm saying but should he not
have picked better he should have okay
yeah like he should have picked better
but my whole point is that when a man
picks wrong there's a consequence when a
woman picks wrong she takes half
but you're not getting half if you've
just had a child for somebody it's not
hard okay okay even if
the number isn't the point you
understand the point i'm making like the
point is that when a woman makes a bad
decision there's no consequence when the
man makes a bad decision there is well
that
that's where we differ i guess because
there is a consequence it even depends
on the society though because um what
you're saying is the woman would take
half right if you go to arab countries
that's not the issue that's not the case
i know but we're not in it but this is
what girls do i'm just understand
clearly but i'm saying clearly in the
context of this conversation we're
talking about the west yeah of course
yeah i'm just telling you like there are
a few cases that it does not get
implemented that way yes but it's the
exception it's not the rule yeah of
course and you can see mergers last
longer then
in those
cultures and that like man can have
multiple wires and i could do all these
things and a woman's not necessarily
going to leave you just because of that
because she understands that the family
she can but most of the time they don't
because they understand because they
don't
i'll take one for the team